so next question
why do you think women like men who've
been with a lot of other women or who
are around many women why do you think
that's so attractive to them even though
they say it's not it always is I mean I
think most girls don't really want to be
telling a guy what to do and instructing
him yeah so I think it's like when a guy
knows what he's doing it's just most
girls would prefer that
and you know we like we like a smooth
talker and how does a smooth talker get
smooth practice
Fair points yeah
it's just so interesting how the
Opposites and this is what goes into my
primal thing is like women have
pre-selection they want what they want a
guy who's liked by other women the
opposite is usually true for men like
sure we like a girl that other men find
attractive but to a point you know what
I'm saying like if every guy is making
some nasty comments
I don't know if I know that she slept
with 20 other dudes in in the same uh
Friendship Circle um that's the same
thing or one huh or one or even yeah or
even one dude I'm just dude I'm super
old school man like I'm not crazy I'm
not gonna I wouldn't relate to a virgin
at this point but I am very traditional
in the sense where if there's a high
body count I'm out
ain't happening for something casual I
couldn't care less though
uh here's another good one can men be
vulnerable with women
what's your tick
um they can't they certainly can and
nothing's stopping them
um but it just depends what outcome you
want and I think a lot of times men are
vulnerable with their women and they
think that their women will look at them
the same and often they don't
at least that's what the men have said I
personally when I first started
listening to Red Pill content I was like
oh yeah you could talk to women like
and then I thought about I thought about
it long and hard and I'm like oh my God
it's crying all the time no do you want
a guy that's always constantly telling
me how how he feels no did it annoy me
when my ex would always be telling me
how he felt yes and so it's like we
don't even know what we want
you I don't know you have to you're
doing God's work because you have this
logic that I just don't see very often
it's just the triggering happens right
away and just people shut down so I'm
just saying I heard what wrote so Rolo
tomasi if you know you ever heard of
roller tomasi have you okay so rule
tomasi is kind of what's coin the king
of the red pill or the the pioneer of
the red pill red pill is I uh
essentially it's a very controversial
group of people and I agree with most of
what they say
um I'm not uh a dating podcast
specifically but I would definitely
consider myself a red pill to a degree
and we'll go deeper into that but
he has written a series of books called
the rational mail their International
best best-selling books I would
encourage men and women to read them
they're phenomenal
and he said that in terms of
vulnerability
if a guy is already masculine already
has it together and is on his purpose
and is doing what he needs to do if he
has moments very very slight moments of
vulnerability a woman will feel
that she's been able to get him to open
up to her and the vulnerability is
acceptable because it's like okay it's
on rare occasion his mom died maybe his
dog died some tragedy happened okay I
can understand I think it's sexy that
this strong tough guy is willing to be
vulnerable with me but if he comes home
and every [__] day there's another
problem of work and his tire popped and
some stupid [__] happened and he's
always constantly complaining there is
no doubt in my mind that that's a big
turn off yeah I completely agree I've
definitely
but it's cold though but real quick MTR
it's a cold truth that men have to
accept because women are going to tell
them no baby it's okay you could cry my
shoulder whenever you want I'm there for
you until they're not it's it's not in
your what it's not in a woman's wiring
just not it's not how they're built yeah
I was going to say that it's in a
woman's wiring to want security and you
cannot provide security in an unstable
environment and if you are rocked by
your emotions in an unstable way
although she's saying oh no I'm gonna be
here for you you know No Cry On My
Shoulder the minute that that tear
begins to drip on her shoulder is the
same in it that she's planning her
Escape Route 100 biological perspective
I'm a biological perspective that's what
often tell dudes do not lean into your
emotions even be careful on your mama
around you know different things that's
going on in your life be careful you
know because she's part of female nature
as well as even though she's she's your
mom and she might use something on you
later on in life so be careful 100 think
about it like this here's a great
perspective you start dating a girl
you're well to do
maybe you grew up wealthy so you don't
have that much uh adversity that you've
been through so you had a pretty good
but you know you're tall you're good
looking you're in shape you have a lot a
lot going for you
and you start going through some work
trouble say you're an entrepreneur and
things aren't going the way you want to
you start losing a ton of money yada
yada and you start complaining to your
your woman and she sees you bitching and
now you go out to some ball you go out
to some ballroom and you're dancing
together and she sees that guy that she
was trying to bang before she met you
and he's there with another girl and he
looks solid meaning he looks confident
there's no tear coming down his face
what do you think is going to happen is
it necessary is there there's of course
no guarantee that she's going to be
thinking of dating him but if two hours
ago you were just sitting on the couch
with her bawling your eyes out and now
this guy's smiling at her with no sense
of emotion whatsoever
there's going to be an innate attraction
where she's saying well that dude
doesn't seem like a [__] like my
boyfriend yeah yeah it's it's always
like a it's the pen situation you know
what I mean if your mom just died of
course you're gonna be like vulnerable
in that particular situation but I think
along with so many uh young feminized
not having father young men out there
some of them don't have a prescription
of how they should be able to deal with
their emotions and especially deal with
their emotions around women that's why I
tell a little dudes like you know you
need Where the boys at you you need
Community you need you need masculine
you need male presence where's your
father at you know talk to them
regarding these things as opposed to
talking to your woman because I'm trying
to tell you them innards are going to
start to dry the hell up as soon as you
start to be overly emotional in front of
her and I think lot of times like women
mislead men because we're not like
conscious of these things like we've
never really had to think about things
from a male point of view a lot of the
time so it's like part of us is like
yeah you can be open with us but we
don't think about the outcomes because I
think it sounds like a it sounds sweet
in your mind right it's like this
butterfly feeling yeah that would be
nice if you could be vulnerable not
realizing that it actually draws you up
inside or we're talking about the small
percentage of men that maybe could be a
little bit like you know the [__]
she'll really respect them because
you're really respected to that part I
mean I was the [__] 100
it was I met my wife during the time
that I was promoting obviously you know
still having a good time weird you know
whatever but we ended up getting married
she is one hell of a woman for putting
through my [__] at the time
uh by the way I don't know her but I
would say and I if I'm wrong you tell me
big reason she probably found you
attractive was because you were so
attractive 100 100
um and probably one of the only reasons
why you know we ended up I ended up
fighting for her also is because she
didn't sleep with me on the first night
which was you know it just didn't happen
at that time right so
um but like I'm somebody who has almost
zero emotions just off the bat
um but I will say that you know
launching I have three companies one of
them being the new Vape company
crazy Market to get into
um but
launching it was probably been the
hardest thing that I've had to do so far
in my business career and here to help
you I'm here to help you home slice
appreciate it
um but you know having her there also
helped me
to she backed me up on things that like
you know for the first time ever I
questioned myself on business or like
financially do I go all in like because
there's you know a lot of opportunity
here you know we're giving people
instant pleasure
in a vape form and you know everybody
just have everybody wants to enjoy
better it's just a fact so
um do I go all in and you know she said
100 go all in but like I guess that's
for me that's my form of you know
breaking down a little bit and opening
up I don't ball so but I'm sure she
respects you enough as a person where
you can you can you have you can afford
to be that vulnerable yeah so that's the
thing though it has to be a happy medium
yeah it's a careful it's a careful dance
like the average guy will hear that at
and think that they should be more
vulnerable but it's like the women are
talking about the the [__] the guys
that are never vulnerable they're like a
little bit would be nice but it's like
the average guy it took me time to get
there though yeah yeah I think you have
to like meet yourself yeah so that
you're able to express your emotions and
what you're feeling accurately and not
just like dump everything on yourself
yes some of my guys just like wanna they
just try to avoid it all together
because it's like you never know what
girl like different girls have different
tolerances for that yeah so that's why
like guys will just you know what I
don't want to play these games
at what percentage can you be two
percent vulnerable ten percent fifteen
percent don't do it the right way it
might piss us off
everything that oh
they say they don't want a gift that
means they really want to get like don't
[__] up like that everything's decent if
they say don't give me flowers get them
everything's the opposite that's what
I've learned everything's yeah okay
not really [__] fine
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible